[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is video number two of Apollo the
Tesla Model S P 100 D and this video is
going to be shot entirely on a different
smartphone camera than the first one
this is the Google pixel XL camera so
this is going to be your first look at
the the 4k video the electronic but not
optical image stabilization that people
have been talking about so much the
superfast laser autofocus all that stuff
is going to be tested and shown dynamic
range etc in this video so Model S is a
completely electric car and that brings
obviously a lot of interesting traits
into the mix and that brings up a lot of
questions in 2016 so this video is
basically the basics the options and the
rudimentary features for those who
aren't familiar so Tesla Motors the
company actually makes two other
vehicles the Model X is another one
the crossover you might have seen the
one with the doors and they used to make
one called the Roadster but the one
that's coming later is called the Model
3
that'll be the less expensive slightly
smaller sedan starting at around $35,000
but that's a completely separate video
and yes of course
the acronym so Model S being electric
means like I said remember the first
video there is no engine at all so there
is a motor between the front two wheels
and another motor they're both about the
size of a watermelon between the back
two wheels and then there's a huge
battery along the bottom size of this
car so you can see right in the front
they used to be a bigger front here when
these cars didn't have a front motor
there would be more space to put things
in the front trunk but yet there's no
engine in this car at all so the main
differentiating factor between Tesla
Model S's is the different battery sizes
and then the different motors the
battery sizes have different amounts of
range the motors have different amounts
of performance so you can get a battery
size between 60 kilowatt hours 75 90 or
100 and then the P will mean larger
performance motors no P means smaller
regular-sized motors and then the D
means dual motors again a motor in the
front and in the back while no D means
just a single motor in the rear and a
little underline you see here basically
means
little extra performance or ludicrous
method that's probably its own separate
video but as you can see P 100 D
essentially represents the peak of what
Tesla's accomplished in terms of
engineering here and 2016 largest
battery highest performance I fully
expect like a P 120 D next year though
like that's got to be inevitable just
based on the way technology words it's a
tech product so just hardware wise I
guess the same way I talk about smart
phones it's a pretty striking car like
it's unique in some ways but familiar
and others like it some people say it
has some Jaguar influence I kind of
agree with that some other people have
seen Aston Martin or Maserati I think so
you'll see a couple of things in
high-tech electric cars that regular gas
cars don't have number one see the front
of this car right here where you
normally have like a big opening for a
grill you don't need that in an electric
car gas cars with engines require a big
air intake to cool the engine with a
radiator in the front so you have all
this cool air going through well since
you don't have an engine you don't have
a huge radiator so all you do really
need to cool is the motors and the
battery on the bottom so they just cover
up the front and you might not like the
way it looks but that's for efficiency
that's way more aerodynamic and that's
kind of a trend with this car is
aerodynamics and efficiency driving
dynamics are all to just maximize your
range so if you remember the handles
from the first video that popped in and
out they stay inside the car while
you're driving for better aerodynamics
all this stuff combined and the shape
means this car has the lowest
coefficient of drag of any production
car so that's pretty awesome
alright so now basically what I'm going
to do is take you through all of the
options available on this car you can
already go to the tehsil website and see
all the options available but in this
video you'll actually be able to see all
the options right so first of all like
we mentioned performance and range you
pick your battery size and you pick your
performance level obviously p100 d being
a high performance 100 kilowatt hour
battery with dual motors and a little
bit of ludicrous mode going on that
means 0-60 in 2.5 seconds which will
probably be its own little video next is
the paint color this particular paint is
called midnight silver metallic I call
it gray I was so split on red versus
gray earlier but I went with great I
already had a red car and I'm like not
trying to get pulled over so you know
what I mean I'm trying to fly under the
radar I think gray
looks pretty dope and then there are the
wheels you can go with either the 19
inch or 21 inch wheels these are the 21s
and you can also go with either silver
or black I think black looks great I
don't know why more people don't get it
and also how about those low-profile
tires next up is the sunroof so you can
go with a hardtop version of this car if
you want but if you do get the sunroof
version then you do get controls inside
the car for opening and closing it via
the touchscreen again the software that
whole UI is going to be its own separate
video but that how sweet is that now the
interior trim this will probably get its
own entire separate video because
there's so much polarizing stuff about
it obviously having a huge 17 inch
touchscreen and all sorts of electronic
controls but the main idea here is yeah
black leather white leather or tan
leather shout-out to those who are brave
enough to go with white leather black or
white headliner and then you can go with
the carbon fiber trim up at the front or
wood I think probably fiber looks a
little more modern on the back you can
choose to have this carbon fiber spoiler
or not it's a baby spoiler but obviously
it does its job of pressing air down and
keeping this car grounded and stable at
higher speeds and then another option is
the Tesla red brake callipers you see
right there which i think looks sweet
it's that little bit of accent of red on
a non red car and they're also included
with any performance version all right
autopilot hardware this is a popular
topic among Tesla owners and enthusiasts
the car already has a whole bunch of
sensors radar and lidar sensors all the
way around the slides back in front of
the car for safety and parking but
there's also a camera up front here at
the top of the car that will read things
like street signs and the lines on the
road in front of you that is what's used
for autopilot that's an option that you
can choose to get or not to get and word
on the street is you will have to
replace this harness for the autopilot
2.0 hardware that'll let it legitimately
drive itself from point A to point B so
this next one's really fun ready smart
air suspension so take general note of
the ride height of the car right now
yeah you can change that automatically
or manually whenever you want and what's
really cool is I you know you normally
ride around on standard it automatically
lowers the car when you're going over a
certain speed but if I choose to go
ahead and manually turn it to high it
will remember the locations where I do
that and
next time I'm in those GPS locations
it'll actually turn the right height of
the car up again so like my driveway for
example I have to turn it up to high
every single time because it's a fairly
high driveway so I'm gonna go ahead and
turn that up and now I'm going to get
out the car and you can see just going
to go ahead and boost the ride height a
little bit and give me a little more
clearance on things like curbs and speed
bumps so the fact that it can do that
automatically based on GPS location is
sweet so those are the options available
on the Tesla Model S hopefully they give
you a good idea obviously a lot of these
questions that I'm answering in these
videos this video series is going to be
based on things that people ask me and
that people are most curious about but
obviously continue to leave your
comments and let me know what you guys
want to see I plan a bunch of videos on
stuff like the software the interior the
upgrade ability of this essentially tech
product but uh yeah this is your test of
the pixel XL camera and a little look
around the inside out of the options and
features available on this car that's
pretty much it thank you for watching
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace
[Music]